[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture on va essayer de vous
aider à faire vos achats de noël avec
des beaux livres
ça fait toujours évidemment extrêmement
plaisir les veaux livre bonjour nathalie
wolf présenter un livre tout à l'heure
qui est qu'on peut dire tout de suite
pour ces deux lions de laure adler corde
le corps des femmes
et puis nous sommes avec jean-yves
maximilien bonjour alors vous êtes
libraire à fontenay le fleury la
librairie s'appelle jms jms cdi 17,2 je
me souviens savent on pense évidemment à
perec
alors c'est pas à perec que ça serait
faire c est la devise du québec à ewood
park alors eh bien c'est justement je me
souviens et pour comment dire se
remémorer de l'histoire du québec et de
l'e2c d'origine française en tant que
c'est le créateur de la librairie été
créés depuis 1990 maintenant qui a
souhaité donner son nom à la librairie
en référence donc cette devise du québec
alors avant de parler des beaux livres
que vous allez de conseiller je vais
peut-être un petit mot de la situation
là-bas et des libres et vont réouvrir
rouvre ça change quand même les choses
même si vous vous pratiquiez ce qu'on
appelle le clic 1 et collecte oui tout à
fait on a pratiqué ça alors lors du
premier confinement c'était un petit peu
les balbutiements mais cette fois ci on
était
simon mieux organisés et puis aussi on a
eu un fort répondant de la part de nos
clients et donc c'est vrai que ça a été
assez réconfortant pour nous de pouvoir
continuer à travailler
évidemment dans des conditions moins
bonnes puisque il n'ya pas le contact
avec le client il n'ya pas le conseil
etc
mais on a pu en effet relativement
travailler d'une façon continue depuis
ce début on copie demande jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant très très très
content de pouvoir ouvre samedi que la
wii c'est quand même ça sent quand même
ça change quand même des choses et ça
permet justement pas au goût aux clients
de venir choisir de venir faire leur
choix eux mêmes
on n'achète pas tout à fait forcément la
même chose quand on peut rentrer dans
une librairie quand on fait juste le
gris gagnent des collectes
alors on va parler de beau livre
justement et se croit que le premier
livre
nathalie de premier league dont nous
parle jean yves et bien c'était délit
terre et mer de vincent munier et
laurent ballesta vous écoute genre eh
oui c'est un par ces temps de
confinement c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être intéressant de pouvoir
s'évader s'est échappé et c'est un
coffret qui regroupe deux livres que
l'un d'eux vincent munier sûr alors là
on a une photo d'eux plutôt delà de la
partie mère de laurent ballesta donc
laurent ballesta qui est un photographe
sous-marin de la faune sous-marine et
avec les magnifiques photos donc de
cette mer autour de la terre adélie
terre adélice est donc un une profession
on va dire française en antarctique au
sud de l'australie et est donc dans la
fondation laurent ballesta lui a fini à
photographier des photos sous marines et
vincent munier des photos dont que sur
la terre donc pour les deux cdd photo
principalement quand même danino sous
marins ou terrestres qui sont pour la
plupart aussi commun c'est-à-dire que
l'on retrouve le faut que sur terre
comme dans la mer et c'était vraiment
des photos magnifiques très bien cadré
près avec des couleurs sensationnel
c'est vrai que c'est un c'est un livre
qui donne aura envie de voyager dans la
nature de cette nature un peu difficile
de l'article soit mais c'est vraiment un
très beau livre de voyage que l'on peut
pas faire aujourd'hui oui ça fait rêver
ça fait exactement alors deuxième livre
abbas était cette fameuse exposition
mathis et alors là on peut on peut se
procurer le catalogue de cette
exposition qui avait dit qu avait lieu
au centre pompidou oui alors c'est une
exposition qui a lieu à l'occasion des
150 ans
de matisse et elle regroupe des oeuvres
telles que du musée d'art moderne de
paris mais également d'autres musées
français et étrangers nicaso le musée
matisse de nice etc et de grenoble
également et donc ce bon mathis alors le
titre de l'exposition a quand même un
sens aussi là comme un roman ça fait
référence à au roman de louis aragon qui
s'appelle mathis roman henri matisse
roman est bon les deux artistes étaient
très liés et est donc aragon a fait ce
cette oeuvre sur sur mathis et et il
était vraiment assez à celje tous les
lots est donc bon matisse on ne présente
pas mais c'est un grand c'est un grand
peintre du 20e siècle
il a traversé et même je dirais plutôt
survolé tous les courants puisqu'il n'a
pas vraiment été dans le cubisme ni un
peu dans le fauvisme ne m'était mais il
a il a en fin de compte transcender tous
ces courants pour avoir vraiment une
personnalité propre et est donc elle est
exposée dans un pot puyehue soit mais
aussi dans ce livre de l'exposition qui
retrace assez fidèlement cette
exposition est d'ailleurs nathalie qu'il
devait aller voir l'exposition qui a pas
pu à cause de l'eau du lac ohrid
vous allez vous pressez vite évidemment
sur ce catalogue c'est ça tout à fait
c'est tellement triste de pouvoir voir
cette exposition à part confiant de
pouvoir aller peut-être la revoir je
sais pas jusqu'à quand elle dure
exactement mais encore un peu de temps
et se compléter l'exposition de ce
catalogue qui a l'air superbe
alors reste dans la peinture google oui
on reste dans la peinture vous allez
nous présenter un livre qui s'appelle
l'amour pente et d'étoilés mais oui
l'amour peintre alors c'est donc un
livre qui consacre donc des peintres que
l'on connaît bateau fragonard aussi
bouché par exemple et donc c'est ce
xviiie siècle qui est un xviiie siècle
d'ouverture après je dirais le règne de
louis xiv qui était surtout la fin de
règne qui était très très austère là
après ce règne là pendant la régence et
ensuite pendant le règne de louis 15
c'est le explosion je dirais des
voluptés et donc à travers ce très beau
livre de peinture on retrace donc ce
xviiie siècle avec ses grands peintres
là qui donc ont consacré une partie de
leurs oeuvres à l'amour courtois et et
aussi à des à des peintures un peu plus
licencieuses et donc c'est un très beau
livre est aussi je dirais une une belle
approche du xviiie siècle
donc il ya des choses un peu oui c'est
ça un peu de liberté de celles de
liberty valance et xviiie siècles à
tulle faut se rappeler que il y a aussi
dansé dans cette période là
donc d'autres artistes tels que marivaux
donc c'est bien mais mes textes d'amour
évidemment oui c'est ce siècle quand
même une grande aspiration vers la
liberté dans tous les domaines merci
beaucoup pour c'est trop lisse et un
magnifique thème de l'amour peintre où
on va on va parler madone est ce que
c'est de l'amour aussi
en tout cas c'est corps des femmes
exactement qu'un autre beau livre à
mettre sous le sapin
écrit par laure adler parution albin
michel 2020 laure adler est ce qu'il
faut encore la présente et elle est
peut-être quelques mots quand même oui
c'est une journaliste écrivain lots
kraft son biographe
elle était conseillère de françois
mitterrand à la culture exactement et
puis directrice de france culture
ces dirigeants font ce que tu as plus
moi et elle avait lancé le cercle de
minuit aussi à la télévision et alors
elle sort par ailleurs un livre un autre
livre qui est une enquête une sorte de
carnet de voyage sur les alors elle
appelle ça le ce pays que nous irons
tous habités un jour là la vieillesse
c'est une ode à l'âge mûr dans voyageuse
de nuit parution grasset 2020 alors
l'oralair en particulier à les
spécialistes du féminisme et des
féministes au 19è et au 20e siècle et
elle s'est intéressée à de grandes
figures féminines
elle a écrit déjà des séries de beaux
livres qu'on qui nous ont marqués et con
qu'on connaît sûrement les femmes qui
lisent sont dangereuses les femmes qui
est écrit vivent dangereusement les
femmes qui aiment sont dangereuses et le
livre que je vous présente aujourd'hui
donc le corps des femmes
il s'inscrit dans ce sillage qu'est
laquelle à creuser alors c'est la
rencontre de l'histoire des femmes et de
peinture et laure adler analyse les
représentations du corps féminin dans
l'histoire et on sait bien que le corps
il est politique et l'histoire de la
peinture montrent qu'il ya eu une
obsession accords ayant donc le corps
féminin
un jour depuis toujours attiré par la
peinture existe ce que jean n'ya pas les
yeux on ne faisait pas beau et donc
justement on va voir la femme dans tous
ses états dans ce livre avec des
représentations mythologiques
on avait une seule entité des
représentations également religieuse
réaliste et puis c'est la femme dans
tous ses états tous les âges la petite
fille épouse la mère et le livre il se
découvre d'abord par sa couverture qu'on
peut voir à l'écran c'est celle qui m'a
attiré camp quand je les ai vus dans une
dans la vitrine d'une librairie de mon
quartier ce beau tableau de ingres très
célèbre la grande odalisque qui est un
tableau qui rayonne par la beauté et la
sensualité que crée le peintre et qu'on
trouve ce tableau au louvre on va
pouvoir de nouveau arpenter alors dans
l'île des trois périodes
une première période qu'ils dont qui va
suivre bien sûr ces périodes qui vont
suivre la conquête par les femmes de
leur autonomie une première période
c'est la femme regarder avec le moment
où courbet manet vont révolutionner le
regard une deuxième période à partie
l'origine du bond des monnaies bien sûr
une deuxième période qui équipe qui
s'étale jusqu'aux années 60
ce sont les femmes qui nous regardent de
très beaux tableaux omanais le déjeuner
sur l'est
toulouse autres avec deux gars et c est
la dernière partie années 70 à
aujourd'hui les femmes se regarde les
femmes ne sont plus seulement des
modèles dans les ateliers et deviennent
des créateurs louise bourgeois frida
kahlo la photographie autre qu'un et
puis cindy sherman exposition devrait
reprendre en photo enfin voilà bombay
cet avis qui fait tout à fait envie donc
le corps des femmes de leurs adverses et
chez albin michel
et puis jean yves maximilien vous avez
parlé de adélie terre et mer de vincent
munier et laurent ballesta de matisse
comme un roman c'est le catalogue de
l'exposition du centre pompidou et puis
de l'amour peintre qui paraît aux
éditions cohen et cohen et puis on a
appris que je me souviens c'est pas
seulement
georges perec c'est aussi la devise du
québec à sa merci infiniment
[Musique]
jean-yves maximilien je rappelle que
vous êtes libraire la de braye jms à
fontenay le fleury merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup d'attali merci patrice
[Musique]